if you only know charlie hunnam as a
badass on a harley wait until you see
his pet cat plus why he didn't land 50
shades of grey or thor all that and more
right here
if you woke up one morning as a famous
actor with money to blow what's the
first thing you'd splurge on for a ton
of today's celebrities it's all about
the footwear
hold the fudge you mean to tell me that
nobody snapped up those bad boys charlie
hunnam certainly had a shoe obsession
during the early part of his career as
well his achilles heel nike air max 90s
speaking to gq in 2013 hunnam explained
that when he was a kid his family
couldn't afford to buy him expensive
shoes but when nike reissued the
infrared colorway in the early 2000s he
couldn't resist he explained
i don't know how it happened but i
became obsessed with buying every
colorway i could get my hands on
although he had amassed a massive
collection he apparently hardly ever
wore them opting to keep most pairs in
their boxes
later in a 2017 interview with elle the
actor admitted that he'd grown up
meaning that his collection of kicks had
to go he said i took out six or seven
pairs that i cared about and i gave the
rest to charity
it was actually a pair of shoes that set
charlie huntum off on the road to fame
success and wealth
in the late 1990s a teenage tunum wanted
to be an actor and was attending film
school
but he was yet to book any work hunnam
explained on the graham norton show that
he found himself christmas shopping on
christmas eve after having spent the
previous four hours in a pub drinking i
was in
jd sports trying on some trainers for my
brother having a bit of a dance around
drunk a woman in the store was watching
his inebriated act so hunnam playfully
blew her a kiss the woman turned out to
be the production manager of biker grove
a long-running family-friendly uk drama
about the goings-on at an urban youth
group hunnam was invited to audition and
he landed a part on the show as a
character named jason it's all laid on
in this game all we have to do is look
good and cash the cheques
although it's been over a decade since
it first graced theaters forgetting
sarah marshall is still widely revered
as one of the finest romantic comedies
of its era who could forget the
ludicrously humorous plight of jason
siegel's peter bretter who regrettably
vacations at the same resort as his
ex-girlfriend superstar actress sarah
marshall and her new beau eccentric
rocker alda snow
every actor in this 2008 classic feels
perfectly picked for their respective
roles but as it turns out the cast
wasn't always set in stone particularly
with one key part believe it or not
russell brand wasn't the first choice to
play aldous snow
speaking to collider charlie hunnam
revealed that siegel who both wrote and
starred in the film had actually
originally written the part for him
hunnam and siegel were close friends at
the time having recently worked together
on the early 2000's comedy series
undeclared hunnam ultimately decided
that the part wasn't right for him but
he admitted that he really struggled
turning his friend down however when he
saw a piece of bran stand up he felt
assured about his decision saying
obviously that's the dude who should
have been playing that role
my relationship with jason gave birth to
that character but there's no way i
could have done it justice the way
russell brand did it's very flexible
before jamie dornan slipped into the
highly provocative role of christian
grey in 2015's 50 shades of grey
universal was apparently all in on
charlie hunnam for the part in fact the
author of the wildly popular literary
series e.l james even made the
announcement over twitter in 2013
however as most people know by now the
pairing just wasn't meant to be
hunnum ultimately dropped out of the
role due to scheduling difficulties
while dornan wound up being a perfectly
suitable replacement some fans still
wonder what could have been had hunnam
not turn down the role as it turns out
the crimson peak actor himself sometimes
does too in 2014 hunnam got candid with
reporters about missing out on what
could have been the role of a lifetime
saying
when you put the time into something
like that and a character comes alive in
your mind it's heartbreaking not to be
able to play him it was definitely kind
of heartbreaking having to say goodbye
to that character and not bring it to
life
to the average joe locking lips with
some of hollywood's most attractive
women might sound like a dream come true
however in an interview with elle hunnam
revealed that he truthfully has a very
different opinion on the matter
admitting everyone thinks it's great to
be an actor and get to kiss a bunch of
beautiful actresses and films but i
actually hate it
while he admits that his longtime
partner morgana mcnellis is not the
biggest fan of watching her main man
gets steamy on screen with another woman
the pacific rim star cites a different
personal phobia that explains his
distaste for spit-swapping scenes i've
got a little bit of germaphobia oh
you're a germaphobe i try to keep it
clean okay okay while this may seem like
a bit of a peculiarity there's actually
a long list of celebs who are huge
germaphobes so he's certainly not alone
in that regard knowing all of the
intimate scenes required for 50 shades
of grey maybe it's best that hunnam
passed on the role of christian grey
after all
throughout the history of the marvel
cinematic universe a number of actors
and actresses have seen their careers
explode due to their heroic on-screen
portrayals although it's now nearly
impossible to envision anyone but chris
hemsworth in the mighty marvel role of
thor the studio originally had its eye
on hunnum for the gig during a press
conference at 2017's cinemacon big
screen achievement awards
charlie hunnam divulged that before they
found hemsworth marvel was interested in
bringing him on to play the god of
thunder in 2011's thor he recalled i
auditioned and i met with the director
and the guys at marvel several times and
it was sort of this awkward dance that
we were having he went on to add that
neither party totally bought into the
idea but he and the filmmakers played
around with the potential casting for a
while why did they ultimately change
their minds hunnam bluntly added then
they found chris hemsworth and that
ended abruptly
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
there are certainly more than a few
hollywood elites who prefer playing some
celebs are consistently single some are
constantly changing who they're dating
and some have even been engaged multiple
times charlie hunnam's public dating
profile is a little less extravagant
compared to most of his peers although
the rumor mill has thrown hunnam's name
into more than a few unverified
relationships he's kept his dating life
pretty close to the chest when the
english star was only 18 years old he
came to america to audition for dawson's
creek although he didn't get the part he
met a fellow actor at the audition named
catherine towne only three weeks later
the two went to las vegas and got
hitched the couple stayed together for
three years before divorcing in 2002. a
few years later hunnam started seeing
american jewelry designer morgana
mcnillis and apparently the two were
simply made for each other they've been
together ever since i've been with my
girlfriend for 14 and a half years
if you're working on a super intense tv
show for an extended period of time
there's bound to be some dramatic
tension build up behind the scenes for a
series like sons of anarchy which was
just as much a character piece as it was
a brutally violent drama it's totally
understandable that the show's actors
would clash at times with the people in
charge speaking to men's journal hunnam
admitted that sometimes things got a
little dicey on set between he and the
show's creator kurt sutter saying
i love that guy but it was hard for us
to work together sometimes because we're
both crazy there has been security
rushing onto set and pulling us apart
before although that may sound a little
alarming there's nothing but love
between the two men today hunnam
referred to sutter as his hollywood dad
in an interview with men's health noting
the shared respect within the pair's
relationship apparently the feeling is
mutual when speaking on the 100 honest
pretty much podcast sutter also had
nothing but flattering things to say
about his show's former lead
you may know him as broody biker bad boy
jax teller from the ultraviolet fx hit
drama sons of anarchy or as the stoic
hero of pacific rim but charlie hunnum
is much more than your stereotypical
action hero i think this guy's dead but
let's check footballs
okay
behind the scenes he's apparently a bit
more reserved than the characters he
portrays and shoot him up blockbusters
in an interview with gq hunnam who
turned 40 in 2020 discussed how getting
older has put his career in a bit of a
transitional phase and that writing has
become his primary focus saying i've
spent these last six to eight months
writing five hours a week i wrote a
screenplay and i wrote a television show
a six-part television show and right now
i'm in the middle of writing a
mini-series he's actually sold four
screenplays to major studios throughout
his career and although none of them
have been made yet he's still really
enjoying the process
of all the screenplays charlie hunnam
has written the most high profile and
notable is his script about the life of
vlad the impaler the 15th century noble
who inspired the dracula story according
to entertainment weekly hunnam began
writing vlad in 2006 and three years
later with the writers strike and the
author landing a regular acting gig on
sons of anarchy development finally
began despite that production still
hasn't begun on vlad more than a decade
after it was first announced
although on screen he often portrays
tough guys and scrappy badasses charlie
hunnam apparently has a major soft spot
for kitty cats in real life
in particular his pet cat george who he
rescued on his roof during a rainstorm i
thought it was a piece of wood he was
lying like this half submerged in a
puddle
and i picked him up and my heart broke
when his longtime partner organa
mcnillis took to her instagram to try
and start a gofundme page for a kitten
in need of surgery her main man came
through in a major way in a post
updating her followers on the kitten's
progress mcnellis wrote charlie just
found out about the gofundme for
stitch's surgery and was very upset that
i did not ask him directly he insists on
covering the remaining cost of the vet
bills apparently she didn't ask him in
the first place because he had already
paid for another cat surgery that month
charlie hunnam is a friend to not just
felines but dogs as well in 2019
entertainment weekly posted an adorable
video to their instagram page showing
hunnam cuddling up with puppies for
national pet day nowadays it seems like
tv reboots spin-offs and long-running
continuations have become an industry
norm
netflix's fuller house breathed new life
into the legendary 90s sitcom full house
in 2016. meanwhile star trek picard
returned sir patrick stewart to his long
extinct star trek role and peacock's
remake of save by the bell brought a few
familiar faces including mario lopez and
elizabeth berkley back to bayside high
while some stars may be all too happy to
slip back into the roles that
jump-started their hollywood careers
charlie hunnam isn't one of them while
the british actor is genuinely grateful
for the show that put him on the map he
has absolutely no intention of ever
returning to the world of sons of
anarchy as jack's teller
he's you know he's not with us anymore
and so i would never bring him back from
the dead for something like that for
charlie hunnam it's all about looking
forward in life
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite stars are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]